katia quels sont les réquisitions et
bien grégory elles sont tombées six mois
avec sursis pour les accusés qui ont
formulé des menaces de mort trois mois
avec sursis sur ceux qui ont envoyé des
messages de harcèlement simple et un
dernier accusé était donc la relaxe est
proposé pour lui au bénéfice du doute
à l'énoncé des réquisitions il a été
temps l'armée et or des avocats de la
défense ont estimé que les réquisitions
étaient juste compte tenu du fait que
les accusés sont des primo délinquants
et ils ont un casier judiciaire vierge
qui expliquerait que les l'acquisition
de soi assez légère je vous propose
d'écouter m d'ils aux arrêts son client
enzo qui est le seul des accusés à
s'être réellement excusé publiquement la
immédiatement dès les auditions reconnu
sa culpabilité présenter des excuses des
dix j'ai été idiot j'ai fait n'importe
quoi il a retiré les messages au bout de
quelques heures d'ailleurs et quand on
lui pose la question quand on lui a posé
la question mais pourquoi vous fait ça
il dit et je sais pas je suis débile je
n'ai pas d'autre explication alors je
vous garantis que enzo n'est pas débile
c'est juste quelqu'un qui a pris
conscience
évidemment tardivement sinon il ne
serait pas là mais ça c'est très
important et le ministère public la
partie civile ont eu lé là la grande
carte est de le reconnaître
j'ai directement regretter je dirais que
tout assumé je pensais la meilleure idée
forcément j'ai regretté puis je
préférais m'excuse auprès d'eux mais là
c'était plus grande pour elle ça doit
pas être facile êtes à trois yeux en
sort plein de messages pour m'excuser
auprès d'elle durant sa plaidoirie
maître malka l'avocat de la jeune fille
a dénoncé une lapidation numérique un
lynchage de mila le cyber harcèlement et
les menaces de mort ce n'est pas rien at
il appuyé il a estimé également qu'il
n'avait pas entendu de prise de
conscience chez les accusés
il a lu des litanies d' insulte
insoutenable envers la jeune femme
broyage de crâne décapitation violent
égorgement le mal de cette génération at
il dit c'est de se croire des offenses
et professionnelles observées maître
malka
il a rappelé que la jeune fille vivait
sous protection policière 24 heures sur
24 et que pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de notre pays ni l'éducation
nationale
même l'armée n'était en mesure d'assurer
la protection de la jeune fille vous
l'avez condamné à la solitude at il
dénoncé
je propose d'écouter maître malka on ne
peut pas continuer dans cette sauvagerie
là et on ne peut pas continuer à dire au
nom du respect du ciel et de dieu on
pourrait ne pas respecter les êtres
humains j'aimerais bien qu'on respecte
un peu plus les êtres humains et leur
loi et un peu moins le ciel parce que
c'est notre constitution
c'est ce que dit notre droit c'est ce
que nous dit notre histoire
c'est ce que dit la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme on ne doit aucun
respect aux religions j'aimerais qu'on
l'entende
une fois pour toutes j'aimerais dire aux
générations aux nouvelles générations
il ne faut pas respecter les religions
c'est un devoir sacré il faut garder
notre esprit critique
alors je rappelle que les treize accusés
ont entre 18 et 30 ans ils expliquent
leur message de haine par le fait qu'ils
appellent au respect des croyances et
c'est actuellement pour le moment des
plaidoiries de la défense
merci catia pour toutes ces précisions
en direct donc du tribunal judiciaire de
paris